the Joe Rogan experience yeah it seems
like it's very loose like there's a lot
of room for [ __ ] Calderon era a bush
administration era it there was a lot of
there was a lot of stuff going on Obama
administration era actor the whole Fast
and Furious thing things kind of cut
went dark for a while yeah explain the
facts a lot of people don't know what
the fast nefarious is it was a they it
sold guns to the cartel
under the guise that this is the way
they would track the guns yes it seems
so fishy oh I learned about it from CNN
and I feel my friends were killed with
some of those guns down there which is
you know everybody talks about the the
US agent that was in Mexico was killed
by some of these guns but there was a
lot of you know Mexican agents and
people civilians killed by these guns as
well so there were very specific types
of guns you know so like imagine
somebody giving you a shopping list
about the types of guns you want right
including in these lists were 50 Cal
Barrett Barrett rifles and FN five-seven
s which are very it's a pistol with a
very high velocity round that it goes
through soft armor like the type of
stuff that was issued to us alright so
all of a sudden we're seeing these space
pistols in the hands of the cartels and
very specific parts of the country we're
like but what a preposterous idea that
they're gonna sell it to the cartel they
could track them well like that sounds
like horse [ __ ] to me that sounds like
someone's trying to make money and they
said ah we'll just say we're selling it
to them to track it well the the
suspicious part is that all of them went
to one specific cartel the Sinaloa
cartel so it sounds like such horseshit
the fact that I mean who went to jail
for that Eric Holder didn't go to jail
oh he should have he should have he
should have I mean there's there's blood
you know people died there was a I can't
say the name but somewhere in in Baja
a little girl lost her arm an agent that
was a friend of mine got killed and the
wife got killed with FN five-seven that
directly related to that whole thing
right so you can go to jail [ __ ] tax
evasion I just got I can get away with
that just think the idea that you would
run that by people and they would go
yeah good idea
yeah give them gun and to be clear I
don't know the realities of that
operation on this side people say it was
it was it was happening way before all I
know is that when that happened nobody
told us and there was definitely some
weird resentment on part of the
government down there people down there
as far as you know and and there was
some weird conspiracy theories going on
as well that could to not be yeah I mean
that seems like it's conspiracy theory
right in front of your face yeah did the
fact oh yeah we just sold them to drugs
or the guns so that we could track yeah
no one's gonna die it's not like a bad
idea the main thing you would hear is
the people settlement and fast a furious
executive privilege lawsuit between DOJ
and House just this is how it and
wrapped up within the last two weeks I
guess really this is just wrapping up
yeah just some settlement on my walk Oh
cuz this is from what nine years ago
Tunisia at least and the guns are still
showing up so I don't know how many of
them I don't know I've never known that
what numbers but I'm last time I we
found some and I actually have images of
the ones we found they were buried in
somebody's backyard inside of a water
barrel and all of them were obviously US
origin guns and like what do you mean
all of them had very specific
accessories on them that nobody else in
the world puts these accessories on
their guns at the US because they're
pretty ridiculous accessory like what
kind of accessories things that had
things letters on them like see you in
hell type things partnerships calls
monastry skulls of the big one yeah and
that's hilarious that a cartoon skull
has from a Marvel comic book has become
a gigantic part of
SpecOps yeah it is it is pretty
ridiculous
well the main rumor down there is like
with conspiracy theory wise and you
would hear all sorts of things you know
because down there there's there's no
such thing as top-secret clearance in
Mexico you know there's like there's
like hey don't say anything you know
that's that's about it you know
so you'd hear crazy crazy things a main
thing was that the US was planning an
engagement you know they're
destabilizing the region so they could
put boots on the ground oh Jesus
you know that was the look like a Cohen
conspiracy theory going on the u.s.
invaded Mexico yeah how [ __ ] crazy
would that be well you know as far as a
reaction on the side of Mexico
people want Pierre then this is again
this is purely speculation and and the
weird rumors that I would hear people
were planning to poison drug loads on
that side to create a health crisis in
the US as a reaction oh that was pretty
like when I heard it's like well he was
talking about this yet you know and so
full-out war almost could be you know
and then you would try and see what
who's doing that you know cartels so the
cartels at the government are the same
thing like what's going on right right
right and again this is just weird stuff
you what accredited there's a crazy
perspective right the cartels would
poison the drugs to punish the Americans
for the military invading the country
yeah yeah so to create a to create a
health crisis in the US so they would
you know have to go back wow I mean ours
you know do they know how many guns they
brought over I've heard all sorts of
numbers we never got told the same
number nearly 2,000 firearms were
illegally purchased for 1.5 million
according to the DOJ inspector general
report [ __ ] hundreds of guns related
recover the United States of Mexico yeah
may 50 cals were so the the and it saw
was an escalation with the cartels right
so we they would get ak-47s and we would
get German maingi threes that were say
around the same caliber and we could
fight back right mm-hmm and then all of
our leadership started rolling around in
armored vehicles so let's get 50 cals do
you know make holes in these armored
vehicles so so there was all it's always
been an escalation you know he's just
crazy guys were getting 50 cows so you
could shoot holes in the armored
vehicles yeah though the cartels were
getting them first and then then we had
to get them because they were rolling
around in armored vehicles so mad max
type armored vehicles they would make
they would first first they would make
them like homemade Mad Max armored
vehicles
they found a few of their online
somewhere one of them was called la
bestia which is like a giant they all
that all that was missing with the guy
with the guitar on the back of it you
know and they would use these to roll
into town and like how would you fight
that right and then you had to get a 50
Cal or get the military to shoot them
from the sky oh my god there's a there's
a famous video from somewhere down in
Mexico where they shoot a Vulcan rifle
down at a cartel member in a car number
vehicle but then you see well you know
well checkmate checkmate government
against the cartel but then you realize
that the cartels like the new generation
cartel Guadalajara have actually downed
helicopters in wall ahora military
helicopters because they have
anti-aircraft capabilities Jesus Christ
so then you now you're like checkmate
cartels you know that's that's how where
does this go like where do we mean how
far does it escalate that's that's
that's the thing that you know you you
have to think about the so killing and
death is not at the industrial level
it's that is being done in Mexico not
just killing but you know disappearing
bodies making body disappear I was a I
was a I was around when they got the
stewmaker the stewmaker was a guy that
worked for the Sinaloa cartel in Tijuana
and he would get rid of bodies using
caustic soda right so he would get
bodies every night and he had these
basically these industrial level just
barrels of it just going his caustic
soda it's a chemical mixture yeah you
can get most of the components at a
hardware store basically it dissolves
bodies you know it would get get some of
this make sure he said and interviews
that he got trained by Israelis that how
to do that so who knows is that true or
not but in the night he said he would
get rid of you know dozens of bodies and
just get rid of everything you know
DNA bone everything so there's a lot of
families on Mexico that are looking for
their kids for years and there's just no
way of giving them a body and the amount
of youth that goes into cartel work and
just gets you know kill there and it's
just it's uh whole generations and whole
towns of women and old men you know
their alcohol which is the coal
generation is just God you know all the
men in the gun I've gone to gone to a
few small towns where like they looked
at me like youth you know a young man
it's like so it's rare at some places
that it's because the men are all
getting killed all getting got got in
the you know in the cartel operations
and killed or just recruited now
forcefully recruited or voluntarily
recruited but you know whole generations
just wiped out
[Applause]